ein griff zur pasta und schon ruft das
regal ein rezept auf dazu die empfehlung
für das passende getränk die kasse
menschenleer
scannt die produkte der kunde zahlt mit
seiner kreditkarte die im autoschlüssel
vernetzt ist
dann führen
bis zum nächsten mal so stellen sich
wissenschaftler die zukunft des handels
vor
hier im saarländischen sankt wendel am
forschungszentrum für künstliche
intelligenz erproben sie die kunden bald
einkaufen könnten schon jetzt sagen
prognosen die deutschen werden jeden
vierten euro im internet ausgeben
deshalb wollen sich geschäfte bei den
forschern rat wie sie dennoch bestehen
könnten
der handel muss davon ausgehen dass
sekunden mehr informationen wollen sie
wollen eine entsprechende transparenz
die wollen verschiedene
serviceleistungen die sie jetzt aus dem
online-handel können damit wächst der
druck der handel muss sich
digitalisieren um schnell und informativ
zu sein
über elektronische etiketten wird
nachschub an lager geordert die
kundeninformationen sind eingeblendet so
erfährt der verbraucher auch auf seine
mobilfunkgerät fakten über
allergieauslöser oder rabatte kommen
bananenchips das bedeutet aber auch dass
der kunde viel von sich preisgeben muss
dann kostenlos registrieren
beispielsweise über seinen fingerabdruck
in dem er sich einfach hier
authentifiziert dann wird automatisch im
hintergrund sei benutzerprofil geladen
natürlich ist es auch verständlich dass
es auch negatives man gibt ja
verschiedene daten von sich selbst preis
deswegen ist auch immer so realisiert
was der kunde selbst entscheiden kann
gibt er die daten preis dann könnte die
mehrwert informationen in saarbrücken in
einem supermarkt von heute an den kosten
sitzen menschen die kunden suchen sich
ihre produkte selbst befragt nach den
vorteilen des intelligenten ladens
reagieren viele skeptisch ich möchte
empfehlungen haben
könnte ich mich fragen können wo es war
es und ich möchte einfach was
persönliches beim einkaufen
mit hätten die zahlen oder schlüssel ist
also
mit sich so gut vorstellen also mir wäre
es lieber wenn es die herkömmliche jetzt
bargeld oder halt mit kraut dennoch sind
sich die forscher einig die
digitalisierung ist nicht aufzuhalten
sie beginnt schon im wohnzimmer mit
produkten die direkt vom tisch bestellt
werden
nicht alle aber viele kostensparende
zeiteffiziente ideen wird der handel
wohl umsetzen so wandert was eben noch
im fernsehen klipp beworben wurde direkt
auf den digitalen einkaufszettel
mit dem geht es dann zurück in die
zukunft